let's do some audience questions first
one is from Annie hey David why is
left-wing terrorism just not as
prevalent as right-wing terrorism this
is a very very hot button and touchy
issue and there are even people who will
deny that the basis of the question is
true but it is true right groups that
study this stuff have made it clear that
in the United States domestic terrorism
overwhelmingly right-wing and not
left-wing couple things that I want to
say number one you used to more commonly
see eco-terrorism we talked about
eco-terrorism earlier this week on a
bonus show in fact and eco-terrorism is
one of the specific subsets of terror
that is considered to be more left-wing
because it's obviously for the good of
the environment which tends to be
something that the left is more
concerned with than the right but that
is diminished greatly over the last
several decades I think the answer is
quite simply when you look at what
motivates a left winger and a right
winger to sort of take personal action
systemically at a fundamental level you
understand why the right is more likely
to go to terrorists a terrorist activity
right so on the Left when you see
left-wing ideology socialism for example
or more social democracy right more
social welfare programs rights for all
the underlying idea is even though it
goes against what the status quo is it
wants to change the status quo it's
about going against sort of corporate
power authoritarian power and it's about
empowering the individual it's about a
Galit arianism it's about non-violence
etc so by its very nature if you want
health care for all because you believe
that health is a right everyone is
entitled to you don't want to go and
start killing people right and that's
one of the real things that that didn't
make sense about the eco-terrorism trend
which is presumably you care about the
environment because the environment
relates to the health of the organisms
on the earth
so you're kind of at odds with that if
you go and you're willing to kill people
in order to improve everybody's health
by saving the environment doesn't really
make sense right that exists with
healthcare for all that exists with
ideas like universal basic income
reducing inequality it's all meant to
lift people up particularly people from
the bottom so it's not an ideology that
at its core lends itself to terrorism
when you look at the right and what
motivates the right especially the far
right you see people who want to for
example impose their worldview on all
others whether it's the Christian
extremists or the gun fetishists or
whoever so if you want to impose your
view on others that is a form of
aggression or violence in and of itself
you're not allowing others to sort of
live freely the way that they want and
you're more likely to take the view that
if they're not gonna come over to my
side I don't even know that they that I
want them alive I don't even know that
they deserve to be alive so there's a
much more direct link between saying
here's what I am becoming an activist
for and I sort of hesitate to call these
far-right extreme terrorist activists
but they probably see themselves as such
so it's much easier to understand why
they would be moved to violence and
terrorism against others in order to
push their ideology I think that that's
the the simplest way I can explain it
it's sort of at its core an issue of
what it is they are activating for yeah
and in thinking of right-wing terrorism
these right-wingers aren't just
right-wing in the sense that they want
lower taxes and no government they're
all the way out there they want to
destroy the government they want to
avenge some atrocities committed by the
government they believe if like the
Oklahoma City bombing to me McVeigh went
and killed 168 people there to avenge
for the deaths at Waco yeah think of
Dylan roof at the Charleston Church I
mean that was an anti diversity thing
that's right wanted to kill black people
specifically right so it is very fringe
it's also that there is a way and again
you have to sort of think about the
internal logic of some of these people
there's a way to think that the problem
you're trying to solve can
harshali be solved by getting rid of
people that are part of the problem
whereas if you just want healthcare for
all yea there's no solution by going out
and killing people I guess you could say
well if we killed the politicians
against health care for all
but it's so antithetical to sort of the
basic tenets of what you're trying to
achieve it just doesn't compute so I
think that for the most part that is the
idea that explains to us why we see so
much more right-wing terror than
left-wing terror and with religion is a
big part of it right so religious
fundamentalism which is which is at its
core a right-wing ideology also gets
people to do violent things and we see
that across religions right we see
extremist Christians extremist Muslims
and extremists and sort of other other
religions as well take to violence in
that way